well first up she is the democratic
congresswoman who represents
california's 13th district barbara lee
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay
barbara how you doing tonight
doing great nice being with you once
again bill oh i appreciate it listen i
wanted you one especially today because
it is the anniversary of 9 11 and as i
mentioned on this show a while ago you
and people have of course said the same
thing all over the media you were the
lone voice
uh after 9 11 to stand up and say maybe
we should not go into afghanistan which
i i
i feel like
that there should be a barber lee award
the barbara lee henry fonda in 12 angry
men award
for being the lone person who stands up
against a group
even when the group is all heading in
one direction and i would want to ask
you tonight aside from the specific
lessons from afghanistan don't you think
one of them is also that people are
sheep and group think is one of our most
dangerous problems
bill i tell you
first of all
let me just say whenever
we're in a moment of crisis i'm talking
about now our emotional
reaction
to
national security crisis and in our
personal lives whenever we are grieving
whenever we're in mourning whenever
we're sad whenever we're angry that is
not the decision not the time to make
important decisions we need to step back
and as members of congress and leaders
we have to step back for a minute and
wait until the moment where we can be
rational and think about and understand
the costs and consequences of the grave
actions that we're about to take and so
yes we needed to be
unified in a response to the horrific
terrorist attacks but and it was not a
partisan moment but in fact we had a
duty and responsibility not to go along
with the flow just because three days
afterwards we wanted to bring
terrorists to justice and so group think
uh is dangerous in many respects but i
think as members of congress we have to
really uh step back for a moment as i
said on the floor and make some serious
decisions not in the moment of grief and
crisis and tragedy
so
so what do you think now we're group
thinking what are we going to look back
on in 10 or 20 years
and say oh we all were sheep on that one
well i don't think it's about looking
back saying we all were sheep i think
it's about really learning the lessons
of the last 20 years
several of which we know already one is
that there's no military solution in
afghanistan if you know the history of
afghanistan you know that there'll never
be a military solution by by the united
states uh and the president was right in
withdrawing our troops absolutely
correct because had we stayed there
militarily for the next five 10 20 years
we'd probably in be in worse shape and
and there's no military solution and
that the military option is always on
the table as it relates to the use of
force secondly we can't go around the
world of nation build i mean can you
imagine how much money we have spent now
bill we spent trillions of dollars and
we spent trillions of dollars that could
have been used for infrastructure for
jobs for health care for education for
domestic priorities in our own country
also to support our troops and to make
sure that our troops have the quality of
life that they so do deserve and that
doesn't mean we don't have to
use our counterterrorism measures and
bring terrorists to justice this is a
very dangerous world and so i think what
we've learned is that we have to use all
of the aspects of our national security
policies and and tools that we have
we have defense of course but we also
have diplomacy development humanitarian
strategies that we can use and we need
to rebalance and reimagine how we do our
national security for the future i think
those are a couple of the lessons
[Applause]
you